Hi there!
Steve Kaufmann here.
I haven't done a video in a long time.
I feel a bit guilty, so I've decided to do one.
I've got my cross-country
skiing shirt on here.
It's been warm, but I went
in for a swim in the ocean
and it was pretty
chilly in there.
Bracing, maybe 17
degrees Celsius.
I'm not sure quite how cool, but
it sure cools you off, so...
Sitting here in the evening I've got
my extra little sweatshirt over my t-shirt.
Today, I want to talk about
efficiency in language learning.
And... Because I've been
thinking about what,
you know, my learning
activities here in Czech.
I started Czech
about 5 weeks ago.
I've been working primarily at LingQ.
I did find some material at home.
An old phrase book
which I listen to.
You know, I find once you get going in
the language you tend to .. buy things.
I was in a bookstore,
I saw this small
book on learning Czech - I don't have
it around here - but it was actually
from a group called the
"Hippocrene Books",
it's "Beginner's Czech
- with 2 Audio CDs".
So, I went through that.
And...
So I had an interesting sort of...
You know, observation.
On the one hand, if I listen to the
easy content in this beginner's Czech,
and they read the text
once at normal speed,
and they read it
very, very slowly
and then they record all the
vocabulary, you can listen to that.
And, of course, the first
time you listen to it,
it's wonderful to be able to understand
everything, because most of my listening,
I guess it's been
divided into two types:
I have the kind of material that has
been created by our members at LingQ,
most of which is, I would say, half of which
is easy and half of which is not easy;
and then I've been listening
to radio Praha - "Rádio Praha";
and I've been listening to this
audiobook "The Good Soldier Švejk".
And, of course, the radio Praha is difficult,
"The Good Soldier Švejk" is also very difficult.
But I have text for that, so I
read it on LingQ, I save my linQs.
I can review
them on my iPad,
I can sit down and go over them in iLingQ many,
many times and then I listen when go running.
So, all of this is just kind of letting
all the language wash over me,
occasionally reviewing
them in flashcards, so...
And I've been
doing mostly that.
And plus, also reading this Czech
newspaper, which I have online here.
Which I go to
everyday and read.
I use the lingQ bookmarklet,
and bring it in.
This is "ČeskéNoviny"
And so, here
is an article:
"Pařížská konference žádá odblokování
zmrazených libyjských fondů".
Yeah, I understand that all.
And I read the article and there's
words that I don't understand
but they want to unblock the
frozen funds and so forth.
But...
And that is just
text that I read,
but I find now that I'm able to read these
newspaper articles, you know, not too bad.
You know, my text in LingQ
is covered in yellow
highlighted words, because these
are the words that I've looked up
and I've seen again
and again and again
and they gradually
starting to stick.
But in "Rádio Praha" when I
listen to those articles,
even though I read them and
save the words and study them
when I hear it, you know,
I understand 30-40%.
So, when I got
back to this
"Czech for beginners" -
whatever it was here -
with 2 CDs, the
"Hippocrene Books",
of course, I understood
just about everything.
But there's still a few words
that I didn't understand.
And then I would
read the text.
And I: "Ahh, now I understand.
Yeah, it's that word,
I didn't quite make it
out when I was listening
and now I listen again
and I still listen.
So, then I started
saying to myself:
Am I better of to
spend a lot of time
trying to nail down
everything in this 10 lessons,
in this beginner book?
Or, am I better
of to continue
listening "Rádio Praha",
reading the transcripts,
saving the words
and phrases,
going of to the Czech
newspaper "ČeskéNoviny",
and reading more articles
about Václav Klaus
and his latest outrageous
statements or whatever?
And, doing a bit of "Švejk" and
just letting the words wash over me.
Because on the one
hand, doing that
has seen my vocabulary
really, really increase.
Where I... It's...
I feel that I've done...
I've achieved greater
progress in Czech in 5 weeks,
than I can't remember
in any other language.
Now, it helps that I did Russian,
the structure is very similar.
The vocabulary is
surprisingly, you know,
50% Russian, or similar to
Russian, 50% quite different.
So, and then in the end, I ended
up saying to myself, you know,
it's very satisfying to
try to nail stuff down.
Listen to this... this video here...
or this video...
This audio CD here.
And listen and listen and listen,
until I nail down every word,
and I nail down every expression
and I listen to it over and over.
But at the end of that I
haven't learned many words.
Because I know most of
the words in this book.
This whole beginner book,
basically I'm there.
You know, there aren't
many words that I don't know,
even though I don't necessarily pick
them up every time when I listen.
So I, you know, I kind of think
you need to do a bit of both.
So, I don't mind doing a bit
of the simple whatever.
Listening to it a few times, it helps
pick up on some pronunciation issues,
it helps on some
structure issues.
But I'm inclined to spend
more and more of my time
simply exposing myself to the
language through interesting content.
LingQing it, seeing the number
of yellow words increase,
and of course, in LingQ the
yellow it's a dark yellow
and as you've known
a little better
it becomes a lighter yellow
and a lighter yellow still.
I think that process is
bringing me more words.
And it's bringing me more
familiarity with the language.
And so...
And then...
I remember when I
studied Chinese,
I basically convinced
myself that
the most important thing in
language learning was efficiency.
Because efficiency
means intensity.
The more efficiently you learn, the
more intense your learning is.
And I felt that 40 years ago when
I was studying Chinese that...
And I did my Chinese... Did the "British
Foreign Service Exam" whatever in...
After 9 months of studying.
The other people took 2 years.
But I did it, you know,
completely like a fanatic.
I was at it 5, 6,
7, 8 hours a day.
And I felt that I
learned it better.
Because I did it so
much more intensely
than these other students who
were taking their time at it.
And so, I got hung up, really
started to think about efficiency.
I developed my efficient
way of learning characters.
And what I thought was an efficient
way of learning the language,
which was to ignore the
grammar explanations,
which was to notice the patterns
and get enough content in me
so that these patterns
start to become natural.
This was my way of becoming
efficient in Chinese.
So, talking about
efficiency.
When I think of what...
how I did it. What I had to do
when I started with Russian
at LingQ, 3-4 years ago.
It was so slow and clunky and...
At times it took 7, 8, 10
seconds to save, you know,
go to the dictionary, get
the meaning, bring it back.
And now it's all there
with a mouse over.
Like, LingQ itself has become
so much more efficient.
And, so therefore in the
older less efficient LingQ
I did relatively more
listening, because
A- it's easier to do,
it's more pleasant;
because it was a bit of a chore
to save lingQs in LingQ.
Whereas now, I find myself doing
more and more reading in LingQ.
Because I'm able to cover
interesting content,
it's the challenge of reading
something new and interesting.
I still listen when I go running,
I listen when I'm in my car.
But I'm doing relatively
more reading.
So...
I mean, everybody...
It's going to depend on what
you like, what you like to do.
But I find it quite efficient
to go after new content.
Especially if I'm familiar
with the context,
because it's almost easier to
understand something that talks about,
I don't know, Libya and the
meeting in Paris about Libya,
when you understand the
context, than to read some
artificial content that has been
written about so and so visiting
their new found friends in Prague
and what they are having for dinner
and all kinds of...
The names of the Czech dishes and stuff
which is too early for me. I'll worry
about that when I get to Prague
and I want to order
something in a restaurant.
So, I think it's more efficient to,
again, to focus on content of interest,
meaningful content and to push yourself
to acquire more and more words.
And to allow this words and
phrases and structures
to become natural through
a lot of exposure.
With LingQ, maybe sliding a bit more towards
the reading that I have done in the past.
And then occasionally to go
back to something very simple
to kind on get some grounding
in some very basic structure,
very basic vocabulary
that you might have
maybe not, you know...
Really, you know,
learned it properly as you could have
on the first or second pass over, so...
It's just a general rant
here on efficiency and
also to update you on
my Czech learning.
I'm going to continue my
input activities in Czech.
And perhaps in a month or
so, maybe start talking
and see where I end
up after 3 months.
See if I'm able to hold up
my end of the conversation
in a few months from now.
So, thank you for listening.
Bye for now.